You may have heard the phrase "The Unreasonable
Effectiveness of Mathematics in the Natural
Sciences." This was the title of a paper
by the physicist Eugene Wigner but even
more fun than the title is the way that he
chooses to open it. The paper begins quote,
"There is a story about two friends who were
classmates in high school..." talking about their
jobs. One of them became a statistician
and was working on population trends.
They showed a reprint to their former classmates
and the reprint started as usual with the Gausian
distribution. The statistician explained
to the former classmate the meaning of
the symbols for the actual population, the
average population and so on. The classmate
was a incredulous and was not quite sure whether
the statistician was pulling their leg. "How can
you know that?" was the query and "What is this
symbol over here?" "Oh", said the statistician.
"This is pi."
"What is that?"
"The ratio of the circumference
of a circle to its diameter."
"Well, now you're pushing the joke
too far.", said the classmate.
"Surely, the population has nothing to
do with the circumference of a circle."
In the paper, Wigner then goes on to
talk about the more general phenomenon
of concepts in pure math seeming to find
applications that extend strangely beyond
what their definitions would suggest.
But I would like to stay focused on this
particular anecdote and the question that
the statistician's friend is getting at.
You see, there is a very beautiful
and classic proof that explains the
pi inside the formula for a normal
distribution and despite there being
a number of other really great explanations
online, see some links in the description,
I cannot help but indulge in the
pleasure of reanimating it here.
For one thing, there is a fun side note
that I didn't learn until recently about
how you can use this proof to derive the
volumes of higher dimensional spheres.
But much more importantly than that, what I really
want to do is try to go beyond the classic proof.
Consider this hypothetical statistician's
friend. What I want to ask is,
can we find an explanation that would
satisfy their disbelief? You see,
they're not just asking for some pure math
proof about a function that was handed down
to them on high. The friend's incredulity was that
circles should have anything to do with population
statistics. Until we fully draw that connecting
line, we should consider the task incomplete.
Those of you who watched the last video on
the Central Limit Theorem will have some
of the backdrop here because there we broke
down the formula for a normal distribution,
which is also called a Gaussian Distribution
and when you strip away all of the different
parameters and the constants, the basic
function that describes the bell curve
shape is e^-x^2. And the reason that pi showed up
in the final formula was that the area underneath
this curve works out, as you will see in a
couple minutes, to be the square root of pi.
So, what that meant for us was that at
some point we needed to divide out by
that square root of pi to make sure
that the area under the curve is 1,
which is a requirement before you can
interpret it as a probability distribution.
In the full formula that you would see, say in a
stats book, this gets mixed together with some of
the other constants. But in its purest form, that
pi originates from the area underneath this curve.
So, step number one for you and me is to explain
that area. But I want to emphasize it's not the
last step. To satisfy the question raised
by that hypothetical statistician's friend,
we need to go further. We
need to also answer why is
it that this function e^-x^2 from
is so special in the first place.
I mean, there are lots of different formulas
you could write down that would give a shape
that you know, vaguely bulges in the
middle and tapers out on either side.
So why is it that this specific function
holds such a special place in statistics?
To phrase our goal another way - can we find
a connection between the proof that shows
why pi shows up and the Central Limit Theorem
which, as we talked about in the last video,
is the thing that explains when you can expect
a normal distribution to arise in nature.
So, with all of that is the goal, first
things first, let's dig into the classic
and very beautiful proof. When you want
to find the area underneath the curve,
the tool for doing that is an integral. As a quick
reminder for how you might read this notation,
you might imagine approximating that area
with many different rectangles under the
curve where the height of each such rectangle
is the value of the function above that point,
in this case e^-x^2 for a certain input x and the
width is some little number that we're calling dx.
We need to add up the areas of all these
rectangles for values of x ranging from
negative infinity up to infinity and the use
of that notation dx is kind of meant to imply
you shouldn't think of any specific width but
instead you ask - as the chosen width for your
rectangle gets thinner and thinner, what
does this sum of all those areas approach?
Of course, all of that is just notation
unless you provide a way to answer that
question and the magic of calculus is that it
provides just that. At least usually. You see,
usually the procedure here would be to find some
function whose derivative is equal to the stuff
we have on the inside, e^-x^2. In other words, we
want to find an antiderivative of that function.
The problem is, for this particular function,
it is provably not possible to find such an
antiderivative. It's a little weird
and beyond the scope of what I want
to talk about here. But basically, even
though there exists an antiderivative,
it is a well-defined function. You cannot express
what that antiderivative is using all our usual
tools like polynomial expressions, trig functions,
exponentials or any way to mix them together.
So, finding this area requires a bit of
cleverness. There needs to be a new trick
that we bring to bear. And the first
step to this trick is easily the most
absurd. We start by bumping things up one
dimension, so that instead of asking for
the area under a bell curve, we ask for the
volume underneath this kind of bell surface.
You could rightly ask, "Why would you
do that? Who ordered another dimension?"
And I'll admit, it's not terribly motivated
right now other than to say watch what happens
when we just try it. And in general with hard
problems, it's never a bad idea to try solving
"cousins" of the problem since that can help
you get a little bit of momentum and insight.
To be clear on how this higher dimensional
function is defined - it takes in two different
inputs, X and Y, which we might think of as
a point on the XY plane and the way to think
about it is to consider the distance from that
point to the origin, which I'll label as "r" and
then to plug in that distance to our original
bell curve function. That is, we take e^-r^2.
You might notice the lines I've drawn
on this diagram make a right triangle,
so by the Pythagorean theorem, x^2+y^2= r^2. So,
in the function I have written where you
see x^2+y^2, you can think in the back
of your mind that's really the square of
the distance from the point to the origin.
The main thing to notice here is how this gives
our function a kind of circular symmetry in the
sense that all of the inputs that sit on a given
circle have the same output. And so, when we graph
this function in three dimensions, it means
it has a rotational symmetry about the Z axis.
Math tends to reward you when you respect its
symmetries. So for a question of computing the
volume underneath the surface, what we're
going to do is respect that symmetry and
imagine integrating together a bunch of thin
little cylinders underneath that surface.
Here, making this a little more quantitative,
let's focus on just one of those cylindrical
shells, where its area is going to be the
circumference of that shell times the height.
You might imagine it as something like the label
on a soup can that we can unwrap into a rectangle.
The circumference of the cylinder, which is
the top side of that rectangle is going to be
2 pi times the radius. And then the height of our
cylinder, the other side of our rectangle is the
height of the surface at this point, which
by definition is the value of our function
associated with that radius, which like I
said earlier, you can think of as e^-r^2.
Now the real way you want to think about this is
to give that a little bit of thickness which will
call "dr" so that the volume that it represents
is approximately that area we just looked at
multiplied by this thickness, dr. Our task now
is to integrate together or add together all of
these different cylinders as our ranges between
zero and infinity. Or more precisely, we consider
what happens as that thickness gets thinner and
thinner approaching zero and we add together the
volumes of the many many many different thin
cylinders that sit underneath that curve.
You might think "This is just a
harder version of what we were
looking at earlier. Three dimensions
should be more complicated than two."
But actually, something very helpful has
happened. First let me clean up a little
by factoring the pi outside that integral. Now
the stuff inside that integral, having picked
up this term "2r" does have an antiderivative.
We can now apply the usual tactics of calculus.
Specifically, that whole inside expression
is the derivative of -e^-r^2. And so,
those of comfortable with calculus know what to
do from here. We take that antiderivative and
plug in the upper bound, which is negative
infinity squared and that gives us zero or
speaking a little bit more precisely if
you consider the limit of this expression
as the input approaches infinity, the
limiting value is zero and we subtract
off the value of that antiderivative at the
lower bound, zero, which in this case is -1.
So, all in all, the whole integral just works
out to be 1, which means all we're left with is
that factor out in front, pi. Evidently, the
volume underneath this bell surface is pi.
And I'll point out in this case it's not wild that
pi shows up because the surface has
this intrinsic circular symmetry.
Still, you might wonder "How does that help
us?" As I said, throughout math, if you face
a hard problem, solving an adjacent problem can
be unexpectedly helpful as a next step. And in
this case it's helpful not just for building
intuition but we can directly relate the three
dimensional graph to our two dimensional graph by
analyzing the volume in a second different way.
You see, the more general way to approach
volumes underneath surfaces is to think
of chopping it up into slices that are all
parallel to one of the axis. For example,
all these slices that are parallel to the
X axis. For example, this right here is
a slice that corresponds to the plane y=0.
You might notice it looks just like a bell
curve and if we write out the function,
this should actually make a lot of sense.
You could just plug in y=0, but to help
see what happens with other slices,
notice how thanks to the rules of exponentiation,
we could also write function as e^-x^2 * e^-y^2.
It factors out nicely. On this slice, that e^-y^2,
is just a number - specifically the number 1.
So this is the same graph we've seen before,
e^-x^2, meaning that the area of this slice
is exactly the thing that we're looking for. It's
the mystery constant which I'm going to give the
name "c". What's nice is there is nothing really
special about this particular slice. If we chose
a different slice corresponding to a different Y
value, it corresponds to multiplying this curve
by a different number. So, it's the same basic
shape just scaled down by that number. Meaning
its area is the same as our mystery constant just
scaled down by some number. That's pretty cool.
Each one of these slices has the same basic
shape just rescaled in the vertical direction.
Which by the way is not at all true
for most two variable functions. This
is very much dependent on the fact that
we were able to factor our function into
one part that's just dependent on the Y and
another part that's just dependent on the X.
Now, to think about the volume
underneath this whole surface,
here's another way we could phrase it. We're
going to compute another integral that ranges
from Y equals negative infinity up to infinity
where the term inside that integral tells us the
area of each one of those slices. And when
we multiply it by a little thickness, dy,
you might think of it as giving each one
of those slices a little bit of volume.
And remember, that term C sitting in
front represents the thing we want
to know. Which itself is an integral. A
suspiciously similar looking integral.
See, if we take the expression on the
top and we factor out that constant C
because it's just a number, it doesn't
depend on Y, the thing we're left with,
the integral we need to compute is exactly
the mystery constant, the thing we don't know.
So, overall, the volume underneath
this bell surface works out to be
this mystery constant squared. Out of
context, this might seem very unhelpful,
it's just relating one thing we don't know to
another thing we don't know except we've already
computed the volume under this surface. We know
that it's equal to pi. Therefore, the mystery
constant we want to know, the area underneath
this bell curve, must be the square root of pi.
It's a very pretty argument but a few things
are not entirely satisfying. For one thing,
it feels a little bit like a trick,
something that just happened to work
without offering much of a sense for how you
could have rediscovered it yourself. Also,
if we think back to our imagined statistician's
friend, it doesn't really answer their question,
which was what do circles have
to do with population statistics.
Like I said, it's the step, not the last and as
our next step, let's see if we can unpack why
this proof is not quite as wild and arbitrary
as you might first think and how it relates
to an explanation for where this function
e^-x^2 is coming from in the first place.
John Herschel was this
mathematician/scientist/inventor
who really did all sorts of things throughout the
19th century. He made contributions in chemistry,
astronomy, photography, botany, he
invented the blueprint and named many
of the moons in our solar system and
in the midst of all of this, he also
offered a very elegant little derivation
for the Gaussian distribution in 1850.
The setup is to imagine that you want
to describe some kind of probability
distribution in two dimensional space.
For instance maybe you want to model
the probability density for hits on
a dartboard. What Herschel showed is
that you want this distribution to satisfy
two pretty reasonable seaming properties,
your hand is unexpectedly forced and even if
you had never heard of a Gaussian in your life,
you would be inexerably drawn to use a
function with the shape e^-x^2 + y^2.
You do have 1° of freedom to control the
spread of that distribution and of course,
there's going to be some constant sitting
in front to make sure it's normalized but
the point is that we're forced into this
very specific kind of bell curve shape.
The first of these two properties
is that probability density around
each point depends only on its distance
from the origin not on its direction. So,
on a dartboard with everybody aiming
for the bull's eye, this would mean that
you could rotate the board and it would
make no difference for the distribution.
Mathematically, this means that the function
describing your probability distribution,
which I'll call "f2" since it takes in two
inputs, X and Y. Well, it can be expressed
as some single variable function of the radius,
r. And just to spell it out, r is the distance
between the point xy and the origin, the
square root of X squared plus Y squared.
Property number 2 is that the X and Y coordinates
of each point are independent from each other.
Which is to say, if you learn the X coordinate
of a point, it would give you no information
about the Y coordinate. The way this looks as an
equation is that our function which describes the
probability density around each point on the XY
plane can be factored into two different parts.
One of which can be purely written in terms of
X. This is the distribution of the X coordinate,
I'm giving it the name "g" and the
other part is purely in terms of
Y. This would be the distribution for the Y
coordinate which I'm temporarily calling "h".
But if you combine this with the assumption
that things are radially symmetric,
both of these should be the same distribution.
The behavior on each axis should look the same.
So we could also write this as g(x)g(y).
It's the same function. And more than that,
this function is actually going to be proportional
to the one we were just looking at. The one that
describes our probability density as a function
of the radius, the distance away from the origin.
To see this, imagine you were to analyze a
point that was on the X axis, a distance r
away from the origin. Then the two distinct
ways to express our function based on the two
different properties tells us that f(r) has
to equal some constant multiplied by g(r).
So these functions f and g are basically the
same thing, just up to some constant multiple.
And you know what? It would be really nice
if we could just assume that that constant
was 1 so that f and g were literally the
same function and what I'm going to do,
which might feel a little bit cheeky
is just assume that that is the case.
What this means is that our answer is
going to be a little bit wrong. The
function that we will deduce describing
this distribution will be off by some
constant factor. But that's no big deal
because in the end, we can just rescale to
make sure the area under the curve is 1 like
we always do with probability distributions.
Now, if f and g are the same thing, this gives
us a very nice little equation purely in terms
of the function f. Remember what this function
f is. If you have some point in the X Y plane,
a distance r from the origin, then f(r) tells you
the relative likelihood of that point showing up
in the random process. More specifically, it
gives the probability density of that point.
At the outset, this function could have
been anything. But Herschel's two different
properties evidently implies something kind of
funny about it. Which is that if we take the
X and Y coordinates of that point on the plane
and evaluate this function on them separately,
taking f(x) times f(y) it should give
us the same result. Or if you prefer,
we could expand out the meaning of
that distance r as the square root
of X squared plus Y squared and this
is what our key equation looks like.
This kind of equation is what's known in the
business as a Functional Equation. We're not
solving for an unknown number. Instead we're
saying that the equation is true for all possible
numbers X and Y and the thing we're trying to find
is an unknown function. In the back of your mind,
you can think we already know one function that
satisfies this property, E to the negative X
squared. And as a sanity check, you might
verify for yourself that it does satisfy that.
Of course, the point is to pretend that you
don't know that and to instead deduce what
all of the functions are which satisfy this
property. In general, functional equations
can be quite tricky. But let me show you how
you can solve this one. First it's nice to
introduce a little helper function that I'll
call h(x) which will be defined as our mystery
function evaluated at the square root of X. Said
another way, h(x^2) is the same thing as f(x).
For example, in the back of your mind where
you know that e^-x^2 will happen to be one
of the answers, this little helper function
h would be e^-x. But again, we're pretending
like we don't know that. The reason for doing
this is that the key property for f looks a
little bit nicer if we phrase it in terms of
this helper function, h. 'Cuz now what it's
saying is if you take two arbitrary positive
numbers and you add them up and evaluate h,
it's the same thing as evaluating h on them
separately and then multiplying the results.
In a sense, it turns addition into multiplication.
Some of you might see where this is going but
let's take a moment to walk through why
this forces our hand. As a next step,
you might want to pause and convince yourself
that if this property is true for the sum of
two numbers, this property also must be true
if we add up an arbitrary number of inputs.
To get a feel for why this is so constraining,
think about plugging in a whole number,
something like h(5). Because you can write five
as one plus one plus one plus one plus one,
this key property means that it must equal
h(1) multiplied by itself five times.
Of course, there's nothing special about five, I
could have chosen any whole number N and we'd be
forced to that the function looks like some number
raised to the power N, and let's go ahead and give
that number a name like "b" for the base of our
exponential. As a little mini exercise here,
see if you can pause and take a moment to
convince yourself that the same is true
for a rational input. That if you plug in p/q to
this function, it must look like this base b^p/q.
And as a hint, you might want to think about
adding that input to itself Q different times.
And then because rational numbers
are dense in the real number line,
if we make one more pretty reasonable assumption
that we only care about continuous functions,
this is enough to force your
hand completely and say that H
has to be an exponential function,
b^x for all real number inputs x.
I guess to be more precise, I should say for all
positive real inputs. The way we defined
h it's only taking in positive numbers.
Now, as we've gone over before, instead of writing
down exponential functions as some base raised to
the power x, mathematicians often to write them
as e^cx. Making the choice to always use e as a
base while letting that constant c determine
which specific exponential function you are
talking about just makes everything much easier
anytime calculus comes wandering along your path.
And so, this means that our target
function f has to look like e^cx^2.
The beauty is that that function is no longer
something that was merely handed down to us
from on high. Instead, we started these
two different premises for how we wanted
a distribution in two dimensions to behave
and we were drawn to the conclusion that the
shape of the expression describing that
distribution as a function of the radius
away from the origin has to be e to the power
of some constant times that radius squared.
You remember I said earlier this answer
will be off by a factor of a constant.
We need to rescale it to make it a valid
probability distribution and geometrically,
you might think of that as scaling it so that
the volume under the surface is equal to 1.
Now you notice that for positive values of this
constant in the exponent c, our function blows
up to infinity in all directions. So, the
volume under that surface would be infinite,
meaning it's not possible to renormalize. You
can't turn it into a probability distribution
and that leaves us with the last constraint which
is that this constant in the exponent has to be
a negative number and the specific value of that
number determines the spread of the distribution.
10 years after Herschel wrote this, James
Clerk Maxwell, who's most well known
for having written down the fundamental
equations for electricity and magnetism,
independently stumbled across the same
derivation. In his case, he was doing it in
three dimensions since he was doing statistical
mechanics and he was deriving a formula for the
distribution for velocities of molecules in
a gas, but the logic all works out the same.
For you and me, if we view this as
the defining property of a Gaussian,
then it's a little bit less surprising that
pi might make an appearance. After all,
circular symmetry was part of this defining
property. More than that, it makes the clever
proof that we saw earlier feel a little bit less
out of the blue. I mean, a key problem solve
principle in math is to use the defining features
of your setup. And if you had been primed by this
Hershel/Maxwell derivation where the defining
property for a Gaussian is this coincidence
of having a distribution that's both radially
symmetric and also independent along each axis.
Then the very first step of our proof which seemed
so strange bumping the problem up one dimension
was really just a way of opening the door to
let that defining property make itself visible.
And if you think back, the essence of the came
down to using that radial symmetry on the one
hand and then also using the ability
to factor the function on the other.
From this standpoint, using both those facts feels
less like a trick that happens to work
and more like an inevitable necessity.
Nevertheless, thinking once again
of our statistician's friend,
this is still not entirely satisfying. Using
the Herschel/Maxwell derivation, saying this
property of a multi-dimensional distribution is
what defines a Gaussian, well that presumes that
we're already in some kind of multi-dimensional
situation in the first place. Much more commonly,
the way that a normal distribution arises in
practice doesn't feel spatial or geometric at all.
It stems from the central limit theorem which
is all about adding together many different
independent variables. So to bring it all
home here, what we need to do is explain
why the function that's characterized by
this Herschel/Maxwell derivation should
be the same thing as the function that sits
at the heart of the central limit theorem.
And at this point, those of you following along
are probably going to make fun of me. I think
it makes sense to pull this last step as its own
video. I realise this is what? The third time in
a row that I've kicked this particular can down
the road. You see, the thing I'm building up to
here involves a combination of the topics from
the last three videos - Convolutions, the Central
Limit Theorem and now the Herschel/Maxwell
characterization of normal distributions.
The traditional explanation that I first learned
to explain why e^-x^2 arises in the central limit
theorem has to do with fourier transforms and
the convolution theorem and it's nice enough,
don't get me wrong, but what I'd like to try
is to share a more elementary description
that's based on this circular symmetry.
The hope is that, together with this video,
it offers a more visceral satisfaction for why
that particular function arises and that maybe
it offers something which would finally address
the incredulity from our statistician's friend.
Oh and one final footnote here - after making
a Patreon post about this particular project,
one Patron who's a mathematician named Kevin Iga,
shared something completely delightful
that I'd never seen before, which is
that if you apply this integration trick
in higher dimensions, it lets you derive
the formulas for volumes of higher dimensional
spheres. It's a very fun exercise, I'm leaving
the details up on the screen for any viewers
who are comfortable with integration by parts.
Thank you very much to Kevin for sharing that
one. And thanks to all patrons by the way, both
for the support of the channel and also for all
the feedback you offer on the early draft videos.